sex trafficking is a big problem in our
valley and now new at six
our i-team is learning more about the
lengths that traffickers will go
to keep their victims in line one woman
accused of running an illegal brothel is
accused of doing just that
with witchcraft the i-team's david
charns here now with those details at 6.
yes so denise court documents say this
woman is accused of sex trafficking at
least three other women
threatening them with witchcraft and
animal sacrifice when police went to
this
illegal brothel they say some walls were
actually
smeared with blood metro police telling
us they arrested this woman 30-year-old
jasmine russo martinez late last month
after
a lengthy investigation into illegal
brothels across the valley
one woman telling police that russo
martinez threatened her with witchcraft
when police searched the house as part
of their investigation
they say they found shrines with blood
from animal sacrifices on the walls
there
we asked metro's vice unit about how
often sex traffickers use this kind of
behavior
many of these men and women who are
being victimized by human trafficking
are being forced by threats of violence
by by coercion by force by fear
to keep them in that situation to keep
them working and keep them being a
victim
so every time a john goes out and
illegally pays a prostitute
they are contributing to that criminal
element
now when police arrested russo martinez
she reportedly told them quote i
only answered to god and when officers
pressed her for more information she
reportedly said
i'm glad you're taking an interest in my
religion
right now russo martinez is in jail and
due in court later this week metro says
it's busted 20
illegal brothels so far this year i'm
david charns 8 news now
david thank you for that